la scuola delle nuvole questo è il sogno
che io ho pensato e ho avuto da sempre
direi soprattutto da quando 14 anni fa
io insegno italiano e latino quindi in
materia assolutamente umanistiche io mi
sono recata all'università degli studi
di milano dal professor degli antoni
grande guru della multimedialità
dell'informatica per presentare insieme
ai miei studenti un lavoro che li avevo
fatto con loro un power point 800 slide
avevamo lavorato tantissimo
i ragazzi avevano letto tantissimo il
latino avevano il letto tantissimo la
storia ci eravamo divertiti moltissimo
avevo presentato questo powerpoint
assolutamente illeggibile ha scritto è
terribile direi però eravamo tutti
contenti perché l'avevano presentavamo a
un grande buco dell'informatica e della
multimedialità
lui ci ha ascoltato con estremo
interesse e poi ha detto ai ragazzi
avete studiato vi siete entusiasmati ho
detto assolutamente sì
a me ha chiesto se io avevo raggiunto lo
scopo certo i ragazzi avevano studiato e
vanno studiato latino abbiano studiato
storia avevano spiato italiano ci
eravamo divertiti
avevamo lavorato insieme molto molto
bene sebbene benissimo adesso prenda
questo lavoro lo metta in un cassetto e
lei professoressa incomincia a studiare
cosa vuol dire la didattica multimediale
era nel 98 io ero già su bene di età
abbastanza vecchia con una storia
comunque universitaria una storia anche
di sturno di notevole per il mio livello
insomma della scuola e mi sono spogliata
di tutta questa veste di docente e ho
incominciato a fare la studentessa è un
cominciato a studiare a studiare insieme
agli assistenti nei laboratori alle
persone che incontravo in questo
piccolissimo ufficio in questa
università un ufficio dove c'erano
pochissime sedie e scrivanie e
tantissime tesi di laurea tutte
accatastate dove tutti quanti si
incontravano c'era sempre la porta
aperta se uno studente passava veniva
preso e scaraventato messo sedere
a con parlare insieme alle altre persone
e ci potevano essere persone di
grandissimo livello
grandi manager grandi studiosi e lo
studente diventava il protagonista e
incominciava a parlare interloquire con
queste persone che mai avrebbe potuto
incontrare poi nella propria vita e la
loro progettualità e la loro creatività
si sviluppava anche nel corso del tempo
perché noi ci incontravamo nella rete ci
incontravamo al di fuori di quelle
quattro pareti questo stesso metodo
io ho incominciato a sentirlo come
esigenza trasportarlo nel mondo della
scuola quando io ho visto i miei ragazzi
che stavano incominciando a parlare un
lessico che io non capivo più che noi
docenti non capiamo più perché loro
parlano con strumenti di comunicazione
che noi non conosciamo
per cui quando nel 2010 è uscito appunto
all ipad in america e io avevo sentito
il professor lotta che parlava degli
ebook questi libri digitali stranissimi
ma si parlava sempre in forma molto
molto teorica io ho deciso di prendere
questi degli ebook ereader se cioè dei
lettori di ebook e ho pensato di
metterli nella classe vedendo veramente
che cosa si poteva fare con questi ebook
readers cioè se effettivamente
rivoluzionavano la didattica come i
grandi universitari dicevano è chiaro
che i miei colleghi erano molto
perplessi da questa mia decisione perché
loro oltre che dire ma i ragazzi non
sanno più leggere e non sanno più
scrivere non sanno più far di conto
non riuscivano ad andare oltre perché
loro si trovavano nella stessa
condizione in cui mi sono trovata io
quando sono entrata in quel famoso
ufficio parlavano un lessico che non si
capiva
noi abbiamo un lessico specialistico
virtualità rete che cosa vuol dire noi
non siamo in grado noi della nostra
generazione di comprendere a fondo i
meccanismi dei nostri ragazzi e quindi
ci dovevamo spogliare della veste dei
professori e diventare noi stessi
studenti e farci guidare dai nostri
ragazzi in questo mondo virtuale
per fare questo ho deciso di prendere
degli ipad in america erano usciti in
italia non erano ancora arrivati
quindi stiamo parlando del maggio del
10 e lì ho ho deciso di farli mettere
tutti in una classe la mia quarta questi
ragazzi che voi vedete in una quarta
liceo scientifico che erano con me da
quattro anni ho chiesto dei
finanziamenti all ufficio scolastico
regionale per la lombardia hanno creduto
in questo progetto e abbiamo dato a
tutti gli studenti a tutti i docenti
questi tablet senza sapere nulla e
quindi senza avere nessuna nessuna
letteratura di riferimento e quindi
abbiamo incominciato a lavorare insieme
a scoprire che cosa potevamo fare con
questa tecnologia
perché non basta a mettere la tecnologia
in classe come si pensa
inondare le scuole di tecnologie questo
e dannosissimo dannosissimo se non si sa
che cosa farne di queste tecnologie
se non si cambia il metodo di lavoro
quindi noi ci siamo messi a lavorare con
i nostri ragazzi in forma laboratoriale
se vuoi entrate nella mia scuola e le
mie classi i banchi non sono mai messi
in porta tradizionale i miei studenti
ascoltano molto poco in forma passiva ma
lavorano loro stessi insieme a noi
ho tolto i libri di testo e ho messo
tanti libri di testo cartacei nella
biblioteca della classe perché i ragazzi
devono leggere moltissimi testi devono
leggere moltissime fonti le fonti
digitali che loro scoprono avendo la
connettività in rete grazie al loro ipad
o qualsiasi tecnologia similare e devono
anche integrare con oli queste
conoscenze con i libri di testo cartacei
che loro devono riamare che loro devono
rileggere e questo soltanto grazie alla
personalizzazione che noi facciamo nella
nostra didattica sui ragazzi
se i ragazzi si sentono protagonisti se
i ragazzi non sono passivamente nel
banco ad ascoltare noi docenti che
parliamo
ma sono loro che creano i loro percorsi
dei percorsi badate bene
interdisciplinari perché vedete questo
strumento che tutti noi conosciamo
diventa inevitabilmente il loro zaino il
loro zaino dove hanno tutto tutto a
disposizione
anno con un click con un click possono
andare nel mondo di internet e inter
scambiarsi documenti possono lavorare in
gruppo pur non essendo fisicamente lì a
scuola quando sono a casa loro
interagiscono con noi continuamente i
miei studenti sono malati ma che
problema c'è mi chiamano i skype mi
chiamano in facetime e loro sono a
scuola come se fossero presente la
lezione non possono perché non hanno la
connessione in quel momento non c'è
problema i miei studenti registrano le
elezioni vanno nei laboratori di
informatica fanno il video della
sperimentazione la mandano via web e
immediatamente ai propri compagni che
sono a casa i quali possono rielaborare
a casa tutto il materiale che hanno
registrato tutti gli appunti che hanno
preso possono chiederci spiegazioni
continuamente collegandoci collegandosi
con noi in rete e possono avere a
disposizione tutto il materiale che noi
docenti mettiamo a loro disposizione
in questi ambienti virtuali in internet
quindi noi interagiamo tutto nelle
nuvole
noi mettiamo tutto il materiale
possibile e facciamo in modo che ci sia
la possibilità da parte degli studenti
di creare il loro sapere solo loro che
scrivono
sono loro che devono leggere sono loro
che non possono più avere un solo testo
che li rende molo indirizzati cioè il
testo unico non fa altro che far
ripetere la lezione ma non acquisirla in
maniera consapevole
la consapevolezza delle conoscenze
avviene solo se ci siano tante tante
fonti e noi dobbiamo insegnare ai nostri
ragazzi che parlano un linguaggio a noi
sconosciuto ancora perché loro sono in
facebook loro sono nel mondo virtuale
loro solo nella globalizzazione loro
solo in via che noi non conosciamo
ecco che allora noi dobbiamo avvicinarli
stare accanto a loro e farci noi guidare
in questo mondo ma nello stesso tempo
noi docenti dobbiamo dare a loro tutti
quei paletti
tutte quelle quei punti di riferimento
che a loro servono per creare la loro
conoscenza per cui loro rielaborano
tutti i loro testi
noi li correggiamo continuamente
insegniamo loro che andare in internet
significa anche conoscere le leggi del
copyright conosce selezionare i siti
scientificamente validi venete
ultimamente nella scuola si parla tanto
di contenuti e di libri di libri
scolastici si pensa che si possano fare
i libri scolastici o dei contenuti
semplicemente per fatti dagli studenti e
dai docenti no dal mio punto di vista
questo non è possibile
i contenuti devono essere
scientificamente validati e devono
essere dati dagli editori che ce lo
devono fornire in modo completamente
nuovo
siamo noi che poi con i nostri studenti
in classe rielaboreremo e i nostri
ragazzi impareranno che alcuni siti pur
bellissimi per loro come skuola.it non
sono validati scientificamente come il
sito della treccani
quindi noi dobbiamo insegnare ai nostri
ragazzi che possono andare youtube
possono andare a cercare le immagini
possono andare nel mondo di google ma
devono avere sapere che esistono delle
leggi dei diritti d'autore
esiste il copyright esiste il creative
commons e loro si devono adeguare a
queste leggi ma questo serve per il loro
futuro serve per imparare a diventare
dei veri cittadini digitali che è quello
che la società oggi vuole che i nostri
ragazzi utilizzano queste tecnologie che
possono diventare lo strumento grazie al
quale possono costruire tutti i loro
percorsi però devono conoscere anche i
limiti che questi strumenti devono dare
nella loro crescita per la loro
personalità quindi noi abbiamo lavorato
con questi ragazzi veramente a
strettissimo vomito e immaginate loro
hanno i loro paderni virtuali quindi
possono scrivere su questi su questi
tablet e catalogare tutti loro e tutti i
loro paderni possono crearsi i loro
ebook multimediali possono crearsi la
loro biblioteca virtuale
che aveva all'interno dei quali
metteranno le loro conoscenze e
creeranno il loro sapere noi professori
che cosa dobbiamo fare appunto guidarli
e stare accanto al loro percorso
studiarli osservarli dare delle
indicazioni e valutare il loro la loro
modificazione ciò che loro imparano e le
competenze che vanno ad acquisire perché
vedete nel mondo del lavoro questo lo
sappiamo tutti non chiedono più lo
studente che sa tutto ma chiedono lo
studente che ha flessibilità che
autonomia che ha capacità di risolvere i
problemi che ha la capacità di
personalizzare la propria il proprio
modo di lavorare sulle esigenze
dell'azienda e quindi noi dobbiamo
insegnare questo agli studenti e questo
avviene tramite seguire anche ciò che
l'europa ci dice le 8 competenze chiave
europee e che permettono proprio la
laboratori età e quindi lavorare con i
ragazzi sempre in gruppo
la condivisione del materiale la
collaborazione e la co creazione cioè
creare insieme e non c'è nessun problema
noi non perdiamo di carisma e non i
professori pensano che magari oddio io
devo scendere dalla cattedra e mettermi
con i ragazzi ho perso il mio carisma
assolutamente no noi acquistiamo un
grandissimo carisma perché nel momento
in cui io chiedo al mio ragazzo di
aiutarmi a risolvere un problema
tecnologico perché ne sa molto ma molto
più di me lui accetterà con molto più
volentieri le a guida che io darò loro
per creare il loro sapere le loro
conoscenze quelle conoscenze
tradizionali che il ministero ci dà e
che noi sappiamo essere fondamentali per
i ragazzi e che noi andiamo a recuperare
utilizzando semplicemente quegli
strumenti che sono ormai una l'ambiente
utilizzato dai nostri ragazzi è un
metodo di studio che abbiamo messo in
atto abbiamo scritto un libro alla fine
dalla quarta liceo di questi ragazzi
l'abbiamo presentato in moltissimi
convegni l'abbiamo aperto ad altre
classi la mia scuola da in prima liceo
da 370 ragazzi sono arrivati a 520 in un
anno
no io insegno in prima 37 10 8 classi
prime con trenta ragazzi davanti abbiamo
oggi nove classi nel mio liceo che
seguono troppi la stessa metodologia
l'abbiamo aperta le altre scuole 25
scuole stanno seguendo il nostro metodo
con degli step determinati e definiti
l'università bocconi ci ha seguito ci ha
studiato ha visto la metodologia che noi
utilizziamo ci sta monitorando quindi
siamo sotto sottoposti a questionari a
valutazioni e documentiamo tutto ciò che
noi abbiamo come risultato perché
vediamo per la prima volta i nostri con
ragazzi veramente contenti di venire a
scuola
ecco noi si annoiano più loro si sentono
veramente protagonisti
questo è un elemento che la rende questa
sperimentazione questo metodo per noi
docenti eccezionale e soprattutto noi
docenti abbiamo imparato anche a
lavorare tra di noi
credete questo è miracoloso cioè il
docente che lavora con gli altri docenti
è miracoloso ma è necessario è
necessario perché se non ci aiutiamo non
potremo mai affrontare un nuovo modo di
concepire la didattica e quelle pareti
così come avveniva in quella stanza del
professor degli antoni si disgregano
perché noi lavoriamo nelle nuvole inter
scambiamo tutto il materiale per cui
queste 25 scuole che interagiscono tra
di loro
scambiano il materiale come se fossero
nella stessa identica classe e io posso
seguire le lezioni di una classe che è
in sicilia quella della sicilia segue le
lezioni che faccio io ciscs inter
scambiamo tratto nelle nuvole e questo
credo che sia veramente un modo nuovo di
fare scuola e un nuovo modo di far
crescere i nostri ragazzi a noi è nato
un centro studi su questo che si chiama
impara digitale un centro studi che ci
permette di far interagire tante realtà
diverse non sono tutti i professori ma
ci sono anche dei personaggi che fanno
parte del mondo dell'information
technology che ci che credono in questo
profondissimo cambiamento
la didattica ed è profondissimo
cambiamento della che deve esserci nella
scuola questo movimento culturale che
noi stiamo portando avanti dal basso e
con questo centro studi stiamo facendo
formazione in tutta italia abbiamo già
formato oltre mille docenti e stiamo
portando avanti qualcosa che noi
crediamo possa veramente aiutare i
nostri ragazzi
ecco questo è quello che noi vogliamo e
che grazie a questo a questo metodo è a
questo nuovo modo di fare didattica
pensiamo di poter ottenere questo è il
mio sogno cioè la scuola nelle nuvole
grazie